I'm still trying to find a little bit of
love some are loving if you will for a
prequel to Greece especially wasn't
expecting it 40 years later
[Music]
that's the upcoming prequel title some
are loving will use the conflicting
lyrics of summer nights as a jumping-off
point to finally show what really
happened when Danny and Sandy first met
[Music]
has she got
the original film based on the hit
Broadway musical became the number one
movie of 1978 and the soundtracks an
all-time bestseller but that 1982 sequel
they approached on the right to do it
and then it didn't happen and and I
didn't think it was going to happen and
then they made it with other people
well it kind of bombed reaction today
was also mixed over another one many
tweeting leave Greece the way it is but
Fox's live version in 2016 with Julianne
Hough did rack up major ratings and won
five Emmys and questions about the
original movie still linger like what
was up with that ending ascending into
the clouds like a fantasy the end of a
fairy tale
[Music]
one fan conspiracy theory says sandy did
drown that summer and the entirety of
Greece is all just a dream
what how could you even think that
a prequel could finally put that two
rats no word if Olivia or John would
return but she's already pondered making
a remake I understand you have an idea
for Greece 3 John I'm eatin and nursing
hurts so are you here for the prequel
because I think we need to give it a
chance I say no but I'll get involved if
we can be first on set that's the way it
always works by the way summer lovin is
still in the very early stages of
development no word when they will start
shooting or when the film will come out
I say don't shoot it at all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]